welcome back to rockstars i'm eric voss
and as one division launches marvel's
next era studio head kevin feige
is opening up about his bigger plans
including
possibly reviving marvel netflix names
like daredevil matt murdock jessica
jones luke cage and
god bless this man he did not rule it
out
which i think we can count as a win we
did it one small step by feige one giant
leap for fan conclusions
i actually gonna break down exactly what
kevin feige said because he's been a
real chatty cathy this week and we gotta
read the tea leaves but i'm also gonna
lay out the likeliest path for feige to
reintroduce daredevil in the titles we
now know to be in this updated mcu
pipeline
oh and before we begin go to omaze.com
new rockstars and enter for your chance
to win a ps5
and support a great cause okay feige
said that when it comes to reviving the
netflix marvel heroes quote oh i think i
got to put on a hat because this is
feige here
well you've certainly seen what we
announced at comic con a year and a half
ago
and on disney investor day a few weeks
ago so that's our focus
but i've been at marvel long enough to
never say never about anything
you better believe it folks feige never
says never
oh darla is howling teenagers
many fans believe that plans are already
underway to feature charlie cox matt
murdock daredevil in spider-man 3. he
perhaps says peter parker's defense
attorney though unlike the other
spider-man three casting reports this
rumor has never been confirmed
in fact feige recently said the fun
thing about online speculation when it
comes to our stuff is how sometimes it
couldn't be more off the mark
and sometimes it's shockingly close and
that's held true for the last few years
but seeing which is which would take all
the fun out of everything
also never say never
look folks kevin feige is super eager to
adapt titles like secret invasion
fantastic four
blade so it's clear the guy intends to
get around to all of it eventually so
knowing that what is the best way
forward with all the titles we know
about
to introduce the netflix defenders
universe characters well a quick
reminder of my theory that the mcu tends
to walk
one of two paths with its titles the
bucky path or the rocket path
the bucky path to tell grounded stories
dealing with human institutions
the rocket path to tell cosmic stories
dealing with fantasy and sci-fi themes
these netflix marvel characters tend to
walk that bucky path right they're
street level there are supernatural
elements but they
rarely leave manhattan let alone earth's
atmosphere so let's start with matt
murdock daredevil where's he gonna show
up in mcu some fans hope that he will
cameo in spider-man 3 as peter parker's
lawyer
i am less certain though that movie is
already looking
pretty stuffed and feige has made it
clear that the movie would go more in
the direction of the multiverse 2 bridge
with doctor strange 2 and i don't know
how much room will be left over for
peter parker's legal troubles i think
it's more likely to see matt murdock
appear in an episode of
she-hulk on disney plus it's gonna be a
half-hour legal action comedy with 10
episodes giving plenty of episodic cases
that could tie into the firm of nelson
and murdoch or
any number of manhattan-based cases
which could include a mention of
kingpin wilson fisk or even a title
coming
sooner in the mcu phase four the falcon
the winter soldier is coming in just two
months and it is confirmed to visit the
fictional marvel setting of madrapore
which not only has ties to wolverine and
the other mutants
but the country rests atop the head of a
giant dragon that in the comics gets
awakened by
the hand also connected to the world of
daredevil so
let's be on the lookout of hand
sightings not just hand sightings you
know the
hand sightings in this falcon winter
soldier series because that could be the
door to
electra to stick no boop daredevil and
to iron fist
and speaking of iron fist i could see
him appearing in a tournament
roster for shang chi in the legend of
the ten rings
i made a video before how there are a
lot of warriors in the marvel world who
could appear on that lineup but really
the one i'm hoping for
is luke cage why well luke cage was
incarcerated at seagate prison just off
the coast of georgia which is also where
in the prime mcu trevor slattery was
held and justin hammer before that agent
of the ten rings broke out slattery now
jessica jones she could show up in an
episode of she-hulk as a private
investigator
but i would be more interested to see
her investigation skills show
up to suss out humans versus scrolls in
the secret invasion series because she
does undergo a squirrel swap in those
comics
now let's not forget punisher frank
castle a guy
i hope we will see show up in moon night
moon knight series will
explore some darker themes of mental
illness of mark specter dissociative
identity disorder and
maybe lay the groundwork for moon knight
and maybe the punisher to be part of an
mcu midnight sons team up with doctor
strange and blade
and again thanks to omaze for sponsoring
this video
omaze is a fundraising platform that
gives you the chance to win
once in a lifetime experiences and
awesome prizes while raising money for
non-profit organizations
you could win a ps5 step into the world
of stunning graphics and super fast
loading speeds with the brand new gaming
console that is sold out everywhere
they have got two that they are giving
away and while you do this you will be
helping support
the life-changing work of my friend's
place they are
a non-profit that assists and inspires
homeless youth to build self-sufficient
lives it's such
a great cause other campaigns on amaze
let you enter for your chance to win a
tricked-out jeep
a trip to the maldives or lunch with ben
affleck and matt damon
and support causes like special olympics
usa and the thurgood marshall college
fund
for your chance to win a ps5
and support a great cause go to
omaze.com new rockstars
but how will marvel handle the casting
charlie cox john berthold kristen ritter
vincent and offering mike holter
i'm gonna be really bummed if any of
these names get recast but
could feige commit to bringing over all
the supporting cast from these series
as well like could he even do that we're
talking a lot of actors a lot of them
have moved on with their careers
if you bring over one of them don't you
kind of have to bring over a lot of them
claire temple rosario dawson's now in
orange makeup elsewhere on disney plus
is ahsoka tano working with john favreau
who was also
foggy nelson in the past life come to
think and wouldn't it be kind of weird
for mike holter luke cage to meet
mahershala ali blade when that same face
used to be cornell stokes
it's kind of a mess right now i could
imagine some batshit multiverse
explanation for how the mcu could cross
over
some marvel netflix actors but not
others like think about it with jk
simmons jamie foxx alfred molina clearly
there's some kind of plans to
explain how all universe faces are now
just in the mcu but again going to kevin
feig use carefully chosen words
we might be overthinking this he might
just use these upcoming titles to
hint at the existence of elements from
the netflix marvel worlds but not yet
commit to the characters themselves
cameoing yet
this would give his fans time to just
move on to new distractions
and as much as i hate it he might recast
obviously kevin feige ain't afraid to do
that and not just back in phase one with
hulk and roadie
feige just swapped out emma fuhrman
cassidy lang from avengers end game with
catherine newton in ant-man the wasp
quantomania
and you all said nothing so let me know
what you want to happen with this
also you can support this channel by
checking out our new latest
obsession shirts called an unusual
couple
one division themed it's got hidden
easter eggs among visions floating
consciousness that you can only find
the augmented reality on your phone how
did they design this i have no idea but
i am so excited to get mine meanwhile
epic hero shop has launched their own
companion shirt with wanda if you care
about keeping this unusual couple
together which you should
and this one also has a secret ar
component secrets
and a reminder that epic hero shop is
giving away 10
ps5s you can enter by subscribing to
their youtube channel epic hero labs and
filling out the form you'll find it at
picaroofshop.com
giveaway every 10 000 subscribers there
will be a
new winner announced there's also a
bunch of ways to get more entries into
the giveaway at that website so go check
it out epic heroshop.com
giveaway follow me at ea boss follow
rockstar subscribe to new rockstars here
on youtube thank you for watching
[Music]
you